[Music]
welcome to another episode of what's up
Prof good day Walter hi Martin are you
doing okay yes I'm still coughing but
otherwise I'm fine well we're just
carrying on through the
ailments otherwise the work won't get
done that's right we have no time for
ailments well this is a subject that we
have dealt with quite a few times but
many times but people keep writing and
saying they don't see the connection
between the Sabbath and the mark of the
beast yeah and and the signs that are
showing that we are nearing the mark of
the beast is so clear so it's just time
to set it straight again yes so this
time we've decided to actually put the
quotes in because we always quote them
off the top of our head and people want
to see them black on white to make sure
is this really the case or is this just
conjecture let's put it on the table and
see exactly where we stand so let's open
with a word of
prayer our heavenly father thank you for
giving us an opportunity to do this
discussion again we ask that you
Enlighten our minds and give us Clarity
of what you said in your word in Jesus
name amen
amen what triggered it was an event that
took place or events that took place
where prominent people are referring
to uh
Christianity and the secular world
coming into
conflict and it was uh it was so
pertinent and so interesting we'll be
showing it in a moment that we thought
the mark of the beast needs to be
discussed again although we have
discussed it many times yeah the thing
is we are like I mentioned before we are
really nearing this um time in history
yes so the more you
can be informed as to what it is and
what to look for the more you will be
prepared for it can prepare for it yes
now this opening slide that we have here
has this Arch quoting Exodus chapter 20
and it says remember there's one
Commandment that starts with remember
and that's the Sabbath
commandment and in the background you
have the Vatican so that's a a very
significant uh picture showing the
actual
conflict that's it between ideologies
and I think we must we must spend some
time making it clear again what the
conflict is all about and how deep does
the rabbit hole
go a prayerful study of the Bible would
show Protestants the real character of
the papacy and would cause them to abore
and to shun it but many are so wise in
their own conceit that they feel no need
of humbly seeking God that they may be
led into the truth now m w she makes a
statement like that it must always be
balanced with the idea that God loves
people true and this is not against
Catholics it's against
Catholicism and it's not against the
Protestant it's protest Fallen
protestantism correct
although priding themselves on their
Enlightenment they are ignorant both of
the scriptures and the power of God they
must have some means of quieting their
conscience and they seek that which is
least spiritual and
humiliating what the desire is a method
of forgetting God which shall pass as a
method of remembering him yeah the
papacy is well adapted to meet the wants
of all these it is prepared for two
classes of
mankind embracing nearly the whole world
those who would be saved by their
merits and those who would be saved in
their sins here is the secret of its
power now if we look at our
backdrop there we have the mark of the
beast hand or for it
question there's two possibilities there
hand or for it mhm and the or is very
important yes and you have the Vatican
over there and you have the woman who is
dressed in purple with all the Crimson
in the
background and this time there are two
cups in our hand filled with
wine and we chose the one with the two
cups because it's these two classes
those who would be saved by their merits
that's one false Doctrine and those
would be saved in their sins that's
another false Doctrine here is the
secret of her power so it's a very
symbolic backdrop and uh uh it's AI
generated so I think it's rather
impressive and uh I think we can say
thank you to Henry for this
one Revelation 1311 and I beheld another
Beast coming out of the earth and he had
two horns like a lamb
and he spake as a dragon I think we've
we've identified this beast at least a
100 times by now and I'm sure people by
the last three episodes will know now
yes who it is and he exercises all the
power of the first Beast Catholicism
before him and causes the Earth and them
which dwell therein to worship the first
Beast whose deadly wound was healed so
this power has influence and he has
capacity
he can cause the whole world to worship
the first beast in other words to pay it
homage yeah to by being obedient to
it and what does he do if we jump to
verse 16 he causes all it's a very big
word both small and great doesn't matter
if you're a professor at the
University or whether you are of a
humble uh origin Rich poor free born to
receive a mark in their right hand or in
their for it the word or is very
important
yeah they don't care whether it's in
your hand or whether it's in your for it
as long as you've got it it's contrary
to what God requires he wants it and
right hand and for it yes and there's a
mark and that no man might buy
yourselves save he that had the Mark or
the name of the Beast or the number of
his name here is wisdom let him that
understands count the number of the
Beast for it is the number of a man not
a computer system it's a humanistic
system Martin it's Humanity raising its
head against God because otherwise God
wouldn't warn against this right true
and his number is 600 3 score and six
well we know who the second beast is it
is the United States of America mhm that
does on behalf of the first Beast that
which she requires yeah and we've seen
how the first Beast controls the Nations
through its secret societies so just to
make that clear again this system
controls the world yes the entire world
doesn't matter whether we're talking
about China or whether we're talking
about New York that's it even in Africa
it does not matter
correct Ezekiel
20:2 moreover also I gave them my
sabbaths to be a sign between me and
them that they may know that I am the
Lord that sanctify
them so there is a sign between God and
man
that he is the one that sanctifies
humanity and that sign is the Sabbath
yeah there it is there it is there's no
way you can get around this let's go to
verse 20 and hallow my sabbaths and
there shall be a sign between me and you
that you may know that I am the Lord
your God so is it possible that somebody
might perceive someone else as their
lord their God yes
is it possible that someone might
perceive that sanctification can come by
another root than by the Lord the god
they usually try all sorts of ways like
Cain did okay so here's here's a point
of conflict is the Sabbath wedged in
there as a pivotal point of
determination exactly so if you are in
doubt on how to have that sign be very
clear between you and God here is the is
the Sabbath there's no two ways about it
the Sabbath is linked to the sanctifying
power of God and he's the only one who
can do it yeah no one else so obviously
there's an enemy that tries to do this a
different way and they can't have the
Sabbath as a sign they must have
something else as a sign that's it so
let's look at Exodus 31:17 it is a sign
the word is oath
between me and the children of Israel
forever for in six days the Lord made
the heavens the Earth and on the seventh
day he rested and he was refreshed
nafash he took a sigh of relief he
breathed and that's the same he wants
when you come and Tabernacle with him on
the Sabbath it's a joy so let's have a
look what strong tells us what is this
sign this is this Hebrew word oath it's
a sign it's a token it's an IGN it's a
miracle it's a Mark it's a signal it's a
Mark it's a banner it's something that
you hold out to people and if you are
against it you'll be irritated by
it try uh try getting a job appointment
and bringing in the Sabbath is it going
to go easy or will it be quite a tough
call at this stage of the Earth's
history it's a nightmare it's a
nightmare all right it's a remembrance
remember it's a miraculous sign it's an
omen it's also a warning
Martin it's a token an IGN a standard a
miracle a
proof so the only way to know which God
you are serving really is through this
sign yes and it's easy actually yeah
which God are you serving Martin well
the one of the Sabbath the one of the
Sabbath the true Sabbath yeah okay so if
you keep the seventh day you are
acknowledging a particular God a
particular deity yeah if you keeping
another day you are acknowledging some
other deity is that logical that's
logical that's what the text
says so why is it a sign because in six
days the Lord made the heavens and the
Earth and any sign or any Mark or any
enzyme has these criteria the name the
Lord
yve what is his title he's the Creator
what is his jurisdiction it's Heaven and
Earth so it is the Seal of God it must
have his name his title and his
territory and only the Sabbath
commandment has that and it spells it
out in the Commandment correct so you
can't really go wrong no now if it is a
seal if it is a sign if it is a Mark
then it is a symbol of
authority and any document of great
importance in the world must have a seal
on it a seal of authority and it must be
signed by someone in Authority I
whatever the name of the person or the
entity is uh the president and then the
jurisdiction whatever the country is
where your jurisdiction counts those are
the criteria that have to be in such a
seal now this sabbath Martin people say
that is it it was a Jewish institution
now how can it be a Jewish institution
if it was instituted in Eden when there
was no Jew correct and then if you go to
the portion that says the Sabbath was
made for man that it does not make it
exclusive for only the Jews no and in
any case the Jews the word actually is a
Judean yes and they are descendants of
Judah yes so this really is something
that applies to the whole world because
it was introduced in Eden but let's just
make absolutely sure Isaiah
56:6 says also the sons of the stranger
that join themselves to the Lord to
serve him and to love the name of the
Lord to be his servants every everyone
that keeps the Sabbath from polluting it
and takes hold of my Covenant even them
will I bring to my Holy Mountain and
make them joyful In My House of Prayer
their burnt offerings and their
sacrifices shall be accepted upon mine
Altar for mine house shall be called a
house of prayer for all people is the
Sabbath only for the Jews Martin no it's
for the all mankind it's For All Mankind
it's the distinguishing Factor between
serving God and serving something else
that's
it Deuteronomy 11:13 to20 and it shall
come to pass if you shall hearken
diligently unto my
Commandments which I command you this
day to take heed to yourselves that your
heart be not deceived and you turn aside
and serve other gods and worship them
therefore shall you lay up these my
words in your heart in your soul and and
bind them for a sign there's that word
again upon your hand that they may be as
frontlets between your
eyes now the Jews took this pretty
literally wrote them out and made a
little plaque tied it to their hands
into their forehead do you think that's
what God had in mind no it must be
internalized in other words you must
have it as a sign on your hand you must
act
accordingly and frontlets between your
eyes you must think
accordingly cognitive yes not or and
right it must be in both places you must
think accordingly and act accordingly
the Beast is satisfied with all yeah as
long as you obey him and you shall teach
them your children speak of them when
thou sest in thine house and when thy
walkest by the way when thy liest down
and when thy risest up and thou shalt
write them upon the doorposts of thine
house and upon thy gates in other words
your whole life must be in harmony with
them yeah what enters into your Gates
what happens in your house must be in
harmony with this system that's the way
God wants it MH let's make sure Exodus
13:9 and it shall be a sign unto thee
upon thine hand and for a memorial
between thine eyes that the Lord's law
may be in thy mouth for with a strong
hand has the Lord brought thee out of
Egypt all right so mark this Mark of God
because strongs defines it also as a
mark must be upon the hand and it must
be in your
cognitive brain area in your frontal
lobe it must
be on the moral issue that drives your
life yes your decisions every single one
you make must be filtered through this
yes and it must be in harmony with the
Lord's law yeah that's the law that must
be stuck here and you filter everything
all right so is it a is it a computer
Mark that he wants or does he want the
law of God to be
inscribed and particularly as we have
seen the Sabbath as the pivotal
commandment giving him the authority to
command it in the first place yes
otherwise we would have once we were
born probably get a stamp on the
forehead that's that two day forever and
the job would be done yeah yes and you'd
be a
robot well in
1956 Martin this is what was advertised
in New York you see the three crosses
and it says come to church on Sunday do
you think Society has changed since 19
1956 I think it has changed quite a
bit I've been alive longer than
1956 so uh in fact I was 7 years old in
1956 so Martin somewhere along the line
things have changed this might have been
portrayed as hate
speech today this would be against the
Constitution that was 1956 and today
this photo comes from
2023 but uh this is what it looked like
in
2024 as
well where they celebrate something
other than Easter on that particular day
and this is a point of conflict this is
basically King of the North King of the
South confrontation that is taking place
here in direct opposite and very public
very very public in your
face it's almost like a challenge it
is now this is what happened very
recently over the Easter period Trump
vows to create Christian visibility day
following Biden's Declaration of trans
visibility day these are two two
different ideologies are they clashing
oh oh completely in opposition and
definitely clashing right this was
published on April the 2nd
2024 former president Trump vowed to
create a Christian visibility day
following President Biden's Declaration
of transgender day of visibility which
happened to land on Easter Sunday this
year now this Easter thing is very
interesting
because uh it is not to be confused with
the p mhm with the Passover okay so
that's very important get this straight
the Passover was a ceremonial
feast and its day was determined by the
moon yeah not to be confused with the
weekly cycle of keeping the Sabbath on
the seventh day not to be confused at
all
but the papacy declared that Easter
would always have to be on a
Sunday and in actual fact it's the Feast
of
ishar and it always takes place on the
Sunday which is not the case with the
Passover it could take place on any day
if the Passover should happen to
coincide with a Sabbath day for example
then it was a high Sabbath yeah so just
to make it plain so when they worked out
with the moon cycle and that year it
fell on the Saturday according to our
Reckoning now it was a Sabbath but it
was a high Sabbath because this was the
correct Passover now the pope changed it
so that it would be a
Sunday and then it was an easy step to
go from Easter Sunday to a weekly Sunday
rest and that became the origin of
Sunday
worship and this is what he said and
what the
H was Biden thinking when he declared
Easter Sunday to be transvisibility day
Trump asked his supporters during
campaign rally in Green Bay Wisconsin on
Tuesday such total disrespect to
Christians the presumptive Republican
nomin KN for presid president promised
that November 5th would be a Christian
visibility day if he is
elected now November 5 is also very
interesting because it also happened to
be guy fox
day now I took this picture of this
article where it says Jesus my Savior
Trump is my
president let's say it's interesting do
we have a clash of Concepts oh yeah do
we have a very prominent portrayal of
King of the North philosophy against
King of the South philosophy it is
crystal clear here are two
mindsets which are going to clash and
here is a
promise Christianity will take its place
again yeah but does it go further than
that is the Bible involved yes is is and
uh Trump is really stepping up the the
pressure
all right let's have a look at what he
says over here this Bible is the King
James version and also includes our
Founding Father documents yes the
Constitution which I'm fighting for
every single day very hard to keep
Americans protected also the Bill of
Rights the Declaration of Independence
and the Pledge of Allegiance are all
part of this God Bless the USA Bible and
just very important and very important
to me to make America great again is our
religion religion is so important it's
so missing but it's going to come back
and it's going to come back strong just
like our country is going to come back
strong and we answer to God in heaven
Christians are under siege we must
protect content that is prog God we love
God and we have to protect anything that
is pro God we have to bring Christianity
back into our lives and back into what
will be again a great nation we must
make America pray again so Mar he's
brought out a Bible which he wants to
promote together with country music yeah
it's with the person that wrote the song
God Bless the
USA right now it's also interesting that
the Bible says that when these things
happen in the Book of Daniel it says so
it will be in connection with all kinds
of music for sure
and then why don't you have this very
interesting other side of the
story and uh famous
atheist says he identifies as a cultural
Christian and is horrified by promotion
of Islamic holiday this also came out in
April
2024 the famous atheist and evolutionary
biologist Richard
Dawkins explained the ID identified as a
cultural Christian in an interview after
learning Ramadan lights were hung on a
street in the UK as opposed to hanging
lights to celebrate
Easter Dawkins was referring to the
mayor of London sadik Khan turning on
30,000 lights for Ramadan the Muslim
holy month on the cusp of Easter weekend
on Oxford Street I must say I'm slightly
horrified to hear that the Ramadan is
being promoted instead dkan said in an
interview with Rachel S Johnson Sunday I
feel that we are a Christian Country Now
Martin does that make much sense to
you if you understand the backdrop yes
it does but if you just this is
cognitive dissonance if you have to look
at it just this is cognitive dissonance
so there on the one hand you have the
ideology that Christianity must come
back God must come back prayer must come
back the Bible must come back and here
you have an atheist who says we're a
Christian country and he doesn't want
Muslim ideology associated with it now M
this is fascinating let's just go into
this a little
deeper so let's just see what his
sentiment to God really is and towards
Christianity and Jesus
Christ we've quoted this before but it's
useful to quote it again in this setting
he writes in the the book The God
Delusion the god of the Old Testament is
arguably the most unpleasant character
in the whole of fiction jealous and
proud of it a petty unjust unforgiving
control freak a vindictive bloodthirsty
ethnic cleanser a misogynistic homop
phobic racist infanticidal genocidal
filicidal pestilential
megalomaniacal
sodamistic capriciously malevolent
bully I think he looked up every
adjective in the
dictionary it is unfair to attack such
an easy target the god hypothesis should
not stand or fall with its most unlovely
instantiation yaave nor his in iply
opposite Christian face gentle Jesus
Meek and
Mild Martin he trashes the whole system
plus Christianity
actually but he's a cultural Christian
so he says so how does this work let's
just hear what he has to say on the
issue well I must say I was slightly
horrified to hear that Ramadan is being
promoted instead I do think that we we
are culturally a Christian country I'm I
call myself a cultural Christian I'm not
a Believer but there's a distinction
between being a believing Christian and
being a cultural Christian and so you
know I I love hymns and Christmas carols
and um I I sort of feel at home in the
Christian ethos I feel that we are a
Christian country in that sense uh it's
truth that statistically the number of
people who actually believe in
Christianity is going down uh and I I'm
happy with that but I would not be happy
if um for example we lost all our
Cathedrals and our beautiful Parish
churches um so I I count myself a
cultural Christian I think it would
matter if we certainly if we substituted
any alternative religion that would be
truly Dreadful that I like to live in a
culturally Christian country although I
do not believe a single word of the
Christian faith well in so far as
fundamentalist Christians oppose
Evolution and think that the world is
was created 6,000 years ago I mean that
that is pernicious nonsense of course I
I don't want to be misunderstood I mean
I I do think it's nonsense but but um
the the Christian belief I mean today is
Easter and and of course I don't believe
that Jesus rose from the dead and I
don't believe you do either so he's a
cultural Christian yes so he's quite
happy to live under Christian Norms he's
quite happy about Easter even the carols
and everything yes he loves the H H and
is dedicated to the culture so he
wouldn't mind a holiday on Easter would
he no would you think mind a holiday
celebrating a sort of mini Easter every
single Sunday especially when it's for
the evolutionary evolutionary Earth yes
it would be marvelous so let's just
consider this a little bit let's take
the first scenario Trump says God has to
come back prayer has to come back the
Bible has to come back that is in other
words a belief system where you believe
in God right yes that is using your
cognitive to say I believe this and
therefore I want these feasts and these
festivals to be there that is receiving
something in your forehead yes this man
was quite happy to say I'm a cultural
Christian I don't care to Hoots about
what they believe it's a lot of
nonsense but I'm happy to go along with
it where would he receive the mark on
the hand
are they both drinking from those two
cups oh for sure and this is the
probably the best example of those two
that will go through that I've never
seen yes and remember the theater for
the final events will be in the
Christian world
yeah all right so now let's make it
quite plain and clear to the people why
it is a point of
contention why is it important
because what does it ENT tell because
especially this Easter time A lot of
people are confused especially Christian
believing Christians because but Jesus
rose on the Sunday so that what's wrong
with celebrating the Sunday then yes all
right Martin so we need to put it quite
plainly that it is a point of contention
for sure and that the world should
really know about it and that the
churches actually do know about it yes
but have decided to do nothing about it
about it okay so let's get right into it
why does the Christian World keep
Sunday let's ask Webster's International
dictory in the 19th edition Sunday soall
because this day was anciently dedicated
to the son or its worship that's pretty
plain Sunday deest dollas of the Roman
Calendar day of the sun being dedicated
to the Sun the first day of the week
that's sha herzer encyclopedia regarding
Sunday
Sabbath a Hebrew word signifying rest
Sunday was a name given by the heathens
to the first day of the week because it
was the day on which they worshiped the
son here's a Bible cyclopedia page 561
so there there's no doubt about it that
Sunday is the first day of the week and
it was dedicated to Sun worship yeah
it's pretty Prett straightforward yeah
who gave the Sunday to the the name the
heathens for for their first day of the
week Daniel 7 verse 25 and he speaking
about the little horn
power that rises up amongst the 10 horns
in other words that rises up amongst the
powers of Europe before three of which
had to to be removed the ruli the
ostrogoths and the vandals didn't they
keep Sabbath those three that were
uprooted there's pretty good evidence
historically that they kept the Sabbath
so they had to be
removed and this power this little horn
power which all reformers identified as
the papal system will speak great words
against the most high and shall wear out
the Saints of the most high so he will
fight against God's
people and He will think to change times
and
laws and they shall be given into his
hand until a time times and the dividing
of time that's the
1,260 year period of papal Supremacy
from 538 to
1798 yeah when the papal political power
was removed by Napoleon yeah that
seemingly deadly wound that it received
but the Bible is absolutely clear that
this power will think to change times
and laws he will attack God's law yeah
and particularly those dealing with time
especially so this is more aimed at
God's laws than human laws yes so let's
see where this is
leading all right let's take a look at a
quote from the Roman DEC cralia this is
their own writing he the pope can
pronounce sentences and judgments in
contradiction to the rights of of
Nations to the law of God and man would
you say that's arrogant completely it's
plain God above above God actually he
can free himself from the commands of
the Apostles he being their
Superior and from the rules of the Old
Testament is that escalating his
arrogance for sure the pope has power to
change times to abrogate laws isn't that
using the exact language of Daniel yep
to dispense with all things even the
precepts of
Christ how arrogant can you be it cannot
be anymore is this in your face this
sounds exactly like Lucifer
okay 1 John 3:4 whoever committeth sin
transgresses also the law for sin is the
transgression of the law that's the
definition of sin in the Bible yeah now
if you're going to change the law are
you transgressing ing it yes absolutely
right for sure so is this a man of sin
talking here
yes so let's just look how he did it so
on the one side here we have the
catechism of the Catholic Church article
257 and on the left you have the law as
it appears in the in the King James
Bible it's also important just to
emphasize that the Catholic Church see
the catechism
as they standard above the Bible
absolutely so the the Bible in the King
James version the first commandment says
I am the Lord thy God which have brought
thee out of the land of Egypt out of the
house of bondage Thou shalt have no
other gods before me if you go to the
catechism it says I am the Lord your God
you shall have no strange Gods before me
it looks similar but there is some
something missing now what is
that The Words which have brought thee
out of the land of Egypt out of the
house of bondage or missing now
why well that makes it the specific God
yes it's a very specific one which one
the one that brought you out of Egypt if
you want a generic God an ecumenical God
then you will have to remove that yeah
so that's exactly what they done because
they're an ecumenical Association MH so
they've taken it out now the second
commandment is a very long commandment
in the Bible Thou shalt not make unto
thee any Graven image or any likeness of
anything that is in heaven above or that
is in the earth beneath or that is in
the waters under the Earth do the
Heathen Nations do that yes they make
Idols of all sorts of things to worship
so so those that are under the Earth in
other words images of dead people do
they put them in their churches yes do
the Catholics do that and call them
saints yeah well if you take uh the
other gods PID and all of these this is
also Idol yes and and if you go to Rome
the statues that they have of Peter they
are actually Heathen statues that
they've just taken in and given them
different names Thou shalt not bow th
eles down to them nor serve them for I
the Lord thy God am a jealous God
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
and showing Mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my Commandments
what is basically saying that if uh you
practice this in your home it's likely
to go to the third and fourth generation
yeah before there will be a change of
heart if ever there will be a change of
heart now Martin would you say that this
commandment would be a stone of
stumbling to Catholicism for sure
because they full of Idols so what is
the second commandment uh in
Catholicism they've just taken it out so
they've removed it it's gone doesn't
exist so now they sit with a problem
they only have nine Commandments mhm
they have to correct that but there's a
very good reason why they have take
taken the second one out and why they've
modified the first one
yeah when it comes to the third
commandment it says Thou shalt not take
the name of the Lord thy God in vain for
the Lord will not hold him Guiltless
that taketh his name in
vain their catechism says you shall not
take the name of the Lord your God in
vain so what has
changed the admonition is gone now
there's a reason for that Martin
because if this commandment is of
God then he is the one that admonishes
you and gives you a warning yes if this
commandment is from another source then
the previous Source cannot admonish you
therefore let's take it out yeah because
it's another deity taking the place of
the first because this is a changed law
that's it so and the punishment is gone
yes the punishment is gone because it's
another lawgiver here yeah if you change
the law it's it's another
lawgiver now the fourth
Commandment it's also a very long
commandment yeah remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy six days shalt you
labor and do all thy work but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
thy God in it Thou shalt not do any work
thou nor thy son thy daughter thy man
servant thy maid servant the cattle
etc for in six days here is the reason
the Lord made the heavens and the Earth
the seea and all that in them e and he
rested on the seventh day wherefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hallowed it it's so surprising to me
that after reading the fourth
Commandment you still can't see that
Sabbath the seventh day was instituted
in Eden and it is the Seal of God it
gives us jurisdiction it it spells it
out clearly it comes from Eden and that
it's the sign yes and it gives the name
y
now their their commandment is now the
third commandment because they've taken
out the second one and a now reads
remember to keep holy the Lord's
day uh they're very crafty it could have
read remember to keep holy the first day
yeah or this they are implying that the
Lord's day is the first day yes but the
Bible in Isaiah 58 tells us quite
clearly that the Lord's holy day is the
seventh Sabbath so this is deception of
the highest order so what have they
taken out Martin well they've taken out
the
entire heart of the document they've
taken out the jurisdiction they've
replaced it but they've changed
something else as well namely the
Sabbath yeah they've changed it to the
Lord's Day implying that the Lord's day
is a day other than the seventh day
which is a lie and remember the only
place where they get that is in the Book
of Revelation where John says he was in
Vision on the Lord's day it doesn't
Define what day it is obviously it was
the Sabbath day because that's the only
day that is the Lord's day and the holy
day but they take it to be the first day
of the week you see right through the
New Testament as well the Sabbath was
kept a holy day yes there was never a
Time Jesus kept it holy the apostles
kept it holy everybody kept it holy the
only thing that they stand on is that
the resurrection was on the first day
yes but it doesn't say that that makes
it the Lord's Day
exactly now let's just make quite sure
about this issue now this is the new
Baltimore catechism and mass this comes
from father Maguire's Baltimore
catechism and mass of
1949 it Bears amongst others the
imprator of Francis Cardinal Spelman
Archbishop of New York Maguire's version
is remember thou keep holy the Lord's
day to children and for whom this
catechism is intended this is explained
by means of the following questions and
answers what is the third commandment of
God already that's wrong yeah let be the
fourth the third commandment of God is
remember thou keep holy the Lord's
day why does the church command us to
keep Sunday as the Lord's Day the church
commands us to keep Sunday as the Lord's
day because on Sunday Christ rose from
the dead and on Sunday the Holy Ghost
descended upon the apostles now who
commands it over here the church the
Catholic the church commands it who
commanded the fourth Commandment God did
God
did what are we commanded by the third
commandment by the third commandment we
are commanded to worship God in a
special manner on Sunday the Lord's day
not they they didn't even mention it as
Sabbath because like you mentioned then
it would be they can't all right so is
the remember gone yeah no it's changed
into command you must worship God in a
special manner on Sunday the other one
said remember the Sabbath day that the
Lord created you right in other words go
back to your creator this is a new
commandment in its entirety so let's ask
them how does the church command us to
worship God on Sunday the church
commands us to worship God on Sunday by
assisting at the holy sacrifice of the
mass now m this is a totally new
commandment it's another lawgiver for
sure this commandment is not in the Ten
Commandments of God and to take part in
the mass this is their famous Eucharist
that they want everybody to partake in
which is a
Perpetual a Perpetual sacrifice when the
Bible clearly says he was sacrificed
once yeah so this means he's being
sacrificed every single Sunday so this
Baltimore catechism is an
Abomination because it is contrary to
the law of god so let's jump to the
fifth commandment honor thy father and
thy mother that thy days may be long
upon the land which the Lord thy God
giveth thee now it's there fourth
Commandment because there one behind
honor your father and your mother so
what's missing again that
portion that your days may be long upon
the land which the Lord thy God giveth
thee now now it's interesting that Paul
refers to this commandment as a
commandment with a promise yeah they've
taken the promise out exactly because
who will fulfill the promise yes it
can't be God because there's a new
lawgiver so it has to be removed that's
a reason why they removed
it sixth commandment Thou shalt not kill
that stays more or less the same seventh
commandment Thou shalt not commit
adultery sixth commandment Thou shalt
not commit adultery but we must remember
Martin that in the law of Moses there is
a long definition as to what this
adultery attains to or what it means and
if we take Catholicism that has been
totally changed particularly by Pope
Francis yeah
yeah the eighth commandment which is
their seventh Thou shalt not steal the
ninth Thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy
neighbor you shall not bear false
witness against your neighbor is their
eighth commandment now they will look
pretty stupid if they end up with nine
commandments so they take the 10th
commandment and they split it into two
yeah the 10th commandment reads Thou
shalt not cover thy neighbor's house
Thou shalt not cover thy neighbor's wife
noise man's servant nor his maid servant
nor his Ox nor his ass nor anything that
is thy
neighbors they divided into two you
shall not cover your neighbor's
wife and you shall not cover your
neighbor
Goods now it's interesting that
protestantism the
lutherans took the Ten Commandments over
from the catechism of the Catholic
Church yeah they didn't take the Bible
version and it's interesting that they
actually switched it around these two
because theirs reads you shalt not cover
your neighbor's house and the rest over
there whereas the Catholic one says you
shall not cover your neighbor's wife so
they switch that round as well which is
very silly yeah uh they at least kept
the order that it is here in the in the
Bible but they switched them round so
Martin what did they remove and if why
let's have a
look they took away the house
right which in the Protestant version is
still there in their one
commandment and they took away your
manservants your laborers mhm male and
female your implements and your
transport that's what they took away
why because they claim the right to
ownership to everything which includes
your house which includes your workers
and which includes your implements and
your vehicles that's why you have to pay
licenses today on all of this because
they don't belong to you you've got a
tax number you have a license number for
your car exactly you have to you have a
registration paper and you have to pay
land tax for your property now the
interesting thing is that
fascism is in a sense doing exactly the
same thing you have the appearance of
ownership but you don't actually have
ownership Rome pertinently says that she
alone has the right to ownership of
property and Etc isn't it amazing that's
directly opposite to God that says he
owns the cattle on a thousand hills yes
they claim they own everything so Mar
this is a totally new set of
Commandments by new lawgiver did they
change times and laws yes we cannot deny
it
right now let's go to the French
Revolution where it becomes pretty
blatant remember that uh the end time
world philosophy comes out of the
bottomless pit in Revelation 11 we
discussed that in quite some detail and
the philosophers that were associated
were people like
Vol now people don't know that these
were Jesuits no they don't was a Jesuit
he was Jesuit trained and they came up
with a different set of Commandments
which they depicted like this with a
bundle of rods which are the fasi it's a
fascist system this is human
rights and above it they had some
interesting things and then of course
the symbol of the Jesuits right there
and this came out of the French
Revolution now if we look at it in a
little bit more detail human rights are
taking the place of the Ten Commandments
of God yeah it's quite plain now what
deity is involved over here well you
have the system which is
fascism which is the Jesuit preferred
system of governance and they have the
serpent the lifegiving serpent the
Eternal serpent with a tail in his mouth
above everything that's Satan worship
mhm and
they worship him through the symbol of
this little frian hat which was the Hat
of the French Revolution what does it
stand for well here's the god
Mitra the sun god the Persian sun god
remember that the Beast has the Beast
has the feet of a bear yeah which is mid
Persian this is Mitra ISM and there's
his little hat that the son God wears so
this is Sun worship yeah so human rights
in the place of God's law is Sun worship
that's it and you find that hat
interesting in a lot of cartoon
characters yes of course smurfs have it
for example
nauy had on so it's a it's a very deep
Rabbit Hole let's not go into that so
let's make quite sure that Rome knows
what it's talking
about this is the converts catechism to
the Catholic Church from 1957 which is
the Sabbath day Saturday is the Sabbath
day why do we observe Sunday instead of
Saturday we observe Sunday instead of
Saturday because the Catholic Church
transferred the solemnity from Saturday
to Sunday do they say they did it they
say they did it and the excuse that they
use is that it's the Lord's day because
he rose on their day right but that is
not why they Chang it they Chang it
because they say they have the authority
to do it all right do they admit
basically that that the apostles never
changed it correct
okay do they say it is their Mark of
authority yes Sunday is our Mark of
authority the church is above the Bible
and the transference of Sabbath
observance is proof of that fact comes
from their own writings do they call it
their Mark yes are they the Beast for
sure therefore is it the mark of the
beast that's that's how it is that's the
way it is whether you like it or not and
it has to do with the law of God yeah
where does it have to be in God's case
in your foret and in your hand you must
think accordingly act accordingly where
does it have to be for them either or
either or as long as you obey them right
and if people have further doubt that
this is old news just go back to
episodes or three episodes and go and
look at that article that the Catholic
news agency put out that said Sunday or
the Lord's
day all right there's another article
from the Catholic world she took the
Pagan Sunday and made it the Christian
Sunday and thus the Pagan Sunday
dedicated to balda became the Christian
Sunday sacred to
Jesus Cardinal Gibbon says of course the
Catholic Church claims that the change
was her act and the ACT is a mark of her
ecclesiastical power do they use the
word mock over and over the Bible says
remember that thou keep holy the Sabbath
day the Catholic Church says no is that
arrogance Changing Times and laws by my
divine power is that even more arrogance
I abolish the Sabbath day and command
you to keep holy the first day of the
week and lo the entire civilized World
bows down in reverent obedience to the
command of the Holy Catholic Church
Father en Wright American Sentinel June
1893 Martin are they in your face here
they blatantly shouldn't every
Protestant say now hang on a minute I'm
not going to go along with this because
God commanded one thing and these
arrogant individuals command something
else true that's a exactly the stand
you're supposed to take not um um no but
we want to go with it I wonder how
blatant they can become let's have a
look as we go
along poas in 1566 commanded by Council
of Trent it pleased the Church of God
that the religious celebration of the
Sabbath day should be transferred to the
Lord's day which they Define as Sunday
catechism Romanus
1867 and remember they're infallible
they can't change it they can't go back
on that no Catholic mirror the Christian
Sabbath is therefore to this day the
acknowledged offspring of the Catholic
Church a spouse of the Holy Ghost
without a word of remonstrance from the
Protestant world are they challenging
protestantism they're actually saying
there you want to complain but you
didn't even challenge this us on this in
fact at the Council of Trent the
Archbishop of Rego said exactly that he
said you say the Bible is your standard
why are you obeying us on the issue of
Sabbath Sunday the Protestants had a
wonderful opportunity at the Council of
Trent to say you're right we should
follow the Bible and the Bible alone but
by following the standard of the
Catholic Church Church they were no
longer a church they were
Rebels that's it because they refused to
give up the Sunday yeah they actually
there right there just became Wayward
daughters yes Catholic Press Sydney
August 25 1900 Sunday is a Catholic
institution its claims to observance can
be defended only on Catholic principles
from the beginning to the end of
scripture there's not a single passage
which warrants the transfer of weekly
public worship from the last day of the
week to the first do they know it yep
therefore they are not just misled or
mistaken they are
arrogant that's it they are the
misleading entity will they rub it into
the faces let's see what the arch dases
of Baltimore had to say if Protestants
would follow the Bible they should
worship God on the Sabbath day in
keeping the Sunday they are following
the law of the Catholic
church in your face
protestantism in discarding the
authority of the Roman Catholic church
has no good reason for its Sunday Theory
and ought logically to keep Saturday as
the Sabbath this comes from the American
Catholic quarterly review of
1883 do they know what they're doing oh
no for sure okay now how arrogant can
you get this is what they say not the
creator of the universe in Genesis
21-3 but the Catholic church can claim
the honor of having granted man a pause
to his work every seven days is that
arrogant that's actually ins sconed in
human rights you have the right to a day
of rest that's it and that's the one
that will be implemented and they will
Implement that human rights it is your
human right to have the day of rest and
the Catholic Church will grant it to
it'll be Sunday that's it and that's why
Richard Dawkins can say I'm a cultural
Christian because it's based on the
human human laws human law
humanism and now reason and Common Sense
demand the acceptance of one or the
other of these Alternatives either
protestantism and the keeping holy of
Saturday or catholicity and the keeping
holy of Sunday compromise is impossible
compromise is impossible they say Martin
so if you do compromise on whose side
are you standing on their side so Martin
if the Protestant
world is speaking against seventh day
adventism who are they obeying Rome Rome
are they then worshiping Rome more than
they worshiping God for sure because
these Bible his words are clear in the
Bible and here you can see directly
whose words it is that you're obeying
okay so could we say to Protestants wake
up oh for sure I wanted to say that a
while back already in this discussion
please people wake up all right the
authority of the church could therefore
will not be bound to the authority of
scriptures because the church had
changed the Sabbath into Sunday not by
command of Christ but by its own
authority Canon and tradition page 263
is this pretty clear so what is higher
tradition or the Bible no tradition wins
again all right Martin should we talk
about the Bible and its Authority again
oh for sure we have to put it straight
what the Bible what it who where's the
authority is that another bone of
contention oh I think so it's a bone of
contention across all spectrums it has
to be because and we've done this but we
have to do it again because the problem
is people don't realize how serious it
is that we need to have the pure word to
know what God says and to know who we
worship yeah how do we tell the world
who we worship by keeping the same
Sabbath that's it it's the sign it's a
sign it's showing the world who's the
authority in your life and those two
cups that this woman is is carrying over
here hey those that will be saved in
their sins and those that will be saved
by their Works those that receive the
mark in the forehead and those that
receive the mark in their hand isn't
that interesting it's precisely what's
happening and where we are heading all
right Catholic record tells us Sunday is
founded not on scripture but on Trad
tradtion and is distinctly a Catholic
institution so the Protestants claim it
as their own but they're making fools of
themselves yeah the New Testament makes
no explicit mention that the apostles
changed the day of worship but we know
it from tradition the new revised
Baltimore catechism Easter Sunday and
Easter Friday who decides the dates the
pope decides the DAT so it's not the
Protestant churches no he decides it
now what does the Lord feel about all of
these Traditions that take the place of
the of the law of God Matthew 15: 36 and
N but he answered and said to them why
do you also transgress the Commandments
of God by your
traditions and you voided the
Commandment of God by your
tradition but in vain they worship me
teaching for doctrines the Commandments
of men what in vain in vain human rights
in vain in vain in vain who gave us our
our rights God gave us our rights so
that document that human nonsense that
they document that they put there is
definitely enough from God no it sounds
beautiful but it's contrary to the law
of God now do the Protestants know this
or are they willfully ignorant or are
they just plain ignorant well I think
they know they know let's have a look
the Episcopal Church is there command in
the New Testament to change the day of
weekly rest from Saturday to Sunday none
this is the manual of the Christian
doctrine we have made a change from the
seventh day to the first day from
Saturday to Sunday on the authority of
the one Holy Catholic and Apostolic
Church of Christ why we keep Sunday do
they
acknowledge that they are worshiping in
vain yeah they're acknowledging that
they succumb to to the authority of the
Catholic Church all
right what about the Lutheran the
observance of the Lord's day is founded
not on any command of God but on the
authority of the church this is in the
albook
confession do they know it yes and they
already again give the authority to the
church above the authority of God right
what about the
Presbyterians a change of the day to be
observed from the last day of the week
to the 1 there's no record no Express
command authorizing this change this
comes from their
writings the Christian Sabbath what
about the
methodists take the matter of Sunday
there's no passage telling Christians to
keep that day or to transfer the Jewish
sabbath to that day this comes from
their Christian advocate of 1942 do they
know oh for sure have they forgotten
right the only problem is it wasn't the
Jewish sabbath it was a human Sabbath
all right but they forgotten yeah is
that why the Commandment begins with
remember
yes what about the congregationalists it
is quite clear that however rigidly or
devoutly we spend Sunday we are not
keeping the Sabbath there's not a single
sentence in the New Testament to suggest
that we incur any penalty by violating
the supposed sanctity of
Sunday these are their own writings
their own words what about about the
anglicans many people think that Sunday
is the Sabbath but neither in the New
Testament nor in the early church is
there anything to suggest that we have
any right to transfer the observance of
the seventh day of the week to the 1 the
Sabbath was and is Saturday not Sunday
church and people 1947 do they know they
know and they very rightly emphasize
that not in the early church is there
anything to suggest
because a lot of people say oh no but
just after the disciples were there they
changed they actually already started
with Paul correct these people know what
about the
Baptists there was and is a commandment
to keep holy the Sabbath day but that
Sabbath day was not Sunday there's no
scriptural evidence of the change of the
Sabbath institution from the seventh day
to the first day of the week this is
their own writing Martin and then
they'll acknowledge that it we're
keeping the Lord day because of either
the Catholic Church changing it or we
because he rose upon it that's the only
thing they go with all right so let's
just make sure again Sunday is purely a
creation of the Catholic Church comes
from the American Catholic quarterly
Sunday it is the law of the Catholic
Church alone American Sentinel the
observance of Sunday by Protestants is a
homage they pay in spite of themselves
to the authority of the Catholic Church
it is
absolutely documented that they have no
leg to stand on yeah and they are
worshiping the beast that's it because
he is the one that made those
laws but the Protestant says how can I
receive the teaching of an apostate
church now they're being
sarcastic this is the Catholic Church
being sarcastic yes this is the
Baltimore Catholic mirror how we asked
have you managed to receive a teachings
all your life in direct opposition to
your recognized teacher the Bible on the
Sabbath question is that a challenge
yeah that's
actually they're laughing in their face
okay in the in their Protestant face
those who follow the Bible as their
guide the Israelites and the seventh day
Adventists have the exclusive weight of
evidence on their side whilst the
biblical Protestant has not a word in
selfdefense for the substitution of
Sunday for
Saturday do they know something these
Catholics do they know that the
Israelites and the seventh day
Adventists are actually keeping God's
law yes and the rest is keeping a
Catholic law exactly and they not um
hiding it they're not hiding it and once
again go and look at that article I'll
put the link of the article again on in
this description of this video then in
the Catholic maray the Catholic church
acknowledges that the Adventists are the
only body of Christians with the Bible
as their teacher who can find no worry
warrant in its Pages for the change of
Day from the 7th to the 1st hence their
appellation 7eventh Day Adventist just
explain the name again because a lot of
people they don't want to have anything
to do with it because the name sounds so
strange sounds so strange they keep the
seventh day because God said keep the
seventh day and they believe in the
second coming of Christ that's why they
are called Seventh Day Adventist does
the Catholic Church know why they're
called seventh day adven precisely
that's what they me so Martin if they
know it so well do we need to be in an
ecumenical council to remind them no no
they know it we don't have to be there
if you are not there with an
Evangelistic purpose then don't go don't
go the Catholic Church changed the
observance of the sa Sabbath to Sunday
by right of the Divine infallible
Authority given to her by her founder
Jesus Christ that's another Christ by
the way
the Protestant claiming the Bible to be
their only guide of faith has no warrant
for observing Sunday in this matter the
Seventh Day Adventist is the only
consistent
Protestant question box the Catholic
Universe bulletin Martin the Rome says
there's only one consistent Protestant
organization in the world and that's the
Seventh Day Adventist and that's the
only church that they acknowledge is
keeping the same laws and standards as
the disciples did okay
so isn't it interesting that both the
Protestant world and the Catholic world
are AR raid against the Seventh Day
Adventist in this issue yeah I always
ask a question for the Youth were the
disciples after Jesus ascended to Heaven
seventh day Adventists of course they
kept the Sabbath they kept the seventh
day and they preached the coming of
Christ in the future so were Seventh Day
Adventist so maybe everybody when Jesus
said go and make disciples must realize
that go and make seventh Adventists
okay now here's a very interesting one
from the St Catherine's Catholic Church
Sentinel and we'll just highlight this
little portion where they say people who
think that the scriptures should be the
sole Authority should logically be
become seventh day Adventists and keep
Saturday holy Martin this is actually
why I am a Seventh Day Adventist because
logically if I want to follow the
scriptures I don't have much of a choice
why do you want to have all sorts of
extra biblical excuses not to keep what
the Bible says
correct now here's an interesting
challenge that Rome issued via its web
page Immaculate heart.com in 20
2003 most Christians assume that Sunday
is the biblically approved day of
worship the Roman Catholic Church
protests that it transferred Christian
worship from the biblical Sabbath
Saturday to Sunday and that to try to
argue that the change was made in the
Bible is both dishonest and a denial of
Catholic Authority that's a bomber do
Protestants try to justify themselves
from the Bible that the new day of
worship is Sunday that's why I'm saying
the whole time that the only thing that
they stand on is that Jesus changed it
when he rose on the first day that's the
only biblical thing that they try okay
but the Bible says that you commemorate
that in the baptism exactly now they're
saying it's
dishonest and they're saying it's a
denial of Catholic Authority if
protestantism wants to base its
teachings only on the Bible it should
worship on
Saturday so M the conflict between the
mark of the beast and the mark of God is
going to take place between seventh day
Adventists and the entire Christian
world that's it and here's a note from
the editor of that
article and it says the challenge issued
by Rome over 100 years
ago remains
because there was a particular situation
in the United States where they wanted
to bring in Sunday laws in
1888 yes and so now he's saying the
challenge issued by Rome then 100 years
ago
remains either the Catholic church is
right or the seventh day Adventists are
right because it was a Seventh Day
Adventist A Jones that argued
in the legislative of the United States
that it was not right to introduce a
Sunday law and they actually won so here
they're saying either the Catholic
church is right or the seventh day
Adventists all right there can be no
other choice that's it once again only
two choices only two choices not three
not four and if one choose neither then
the whole doctrine of solos script
collapses and with it the pillar upon
which all of protestantism
stands what one has left then is an
invented religion an invented God an
invented set of beliefs that suits man's
purpose and not the creators like Satan
and Luther before them they throw them
in the same category Protestants have
spoken the Creed in action and in
thought if not in word I will not serve
whom the Catholic Church yeah
M there can be no other church either
you're a Catholic and you're with the
Catholics like the Protestants or you
have to be a Seventh Day Adventist this
is their words not mine and doesn't it
qualify what the Bible also
says you will the qualification for
being the remnant Church yes you have to
keep the Commandments of God and keep
and hold to the testimony of Jesus
that's it so and that is then the
Seventh Adventist Church and it stands
opposite to the other one yes so let's
just look at this verse in Isaiah
66 for as the new heavens and the new
Earth which I will make shall remain
before me says the Lord so shall your
seed and your name remain and shall come
to pass from one new moon to another and
from one Sabbath to another shall All
Flesh come to worship before me says the
Lord will the Sabbath remain in the
world to come yes in heaven so there
will be a monthly festival and there
will be a weekly
Festival so what happens in the monthly
Festival I assume that the Tree of Life
Bears its fruit once a month because
that's what the Bible says so there will
be a Tree of Life Festival once a month
and there will be a Sabbath once a week
and the Tree of Life is In The City the
New
Jerusalem now what if the Sabbath will
continue throughout all
eternity did the papacy then eventually
succeed in getting rid of it no so who
has to be gotten rid of unfortunately
that the papacy and that'll take place
in the plagues yeah so M that is the
long and the short of it the mark of the
beast is exactly what we have always
said that it is it is enforced Sunday
what ship MH and if you comply you're
paying homage to the Beast who will
force you the United States of America
will be the first to introduce the
legislation followed by other nations
and the whole world will come to the
choice and those who are convinced by
the Bible
incorrectly will have the mark in their
fored yeah and those Like Richard
Dawkins who say I'm a cultural Christian
or those those that are new ages and say
they are Earth people will be culturally
obedient to the command of the Holy
Catholic church and they will receive
the mark in their
hand that's the choice I prefer to have
the mark of God the sign of God in my
forehead and in my hand amen I agree
let's
pray Heavenly
Father we are fast approaching that
decision and it is a decision of
authority who do
we who do we acknowledge as the
authority in our
lives help us to make the right decision
lest we lose eternal life is my prayer
in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]